went when Denzel Washington accepted his
award that evening and I was given the
honorary award the same evening it was a
it was especially in the community that
I was getting an honorary award for a
body of work and Denzel Washington was
receiving the Academy Award Best Actor
Award for a job most magnificently done
was pregnant with all kinds of things it
represented progress it represented the
dimensionalizing of the film industry
it meant the embracing of a kind of
democracy that had been very long and
maturing it was it was an example of the
persistence and effort and determination
of young people of color not just
African Americans but but Hispanic and
Asian people who too were sort of
minimalized and in American films was
too too long it was a spectacular
spectacular evening I pay I paid them
and I pay now great respect Denzel
Washington he has been a quintessential
element in the finest of all American
actors
God is great from the bottom of my heart
I thank you all 40 years I've been
chasing Sidney they finally give it to
me what they do they give it to him the
same night
I'll always be chasing you Sydney I'll
always be following in your footsteps
there's nothing I would rather do
nothing
god bless you and when he said about me
what he did say about me I was proud
obviously but I was grateful because his
following me as he did he had taken the
concept of african-americans and films
to a place where I couldn't I didn't and
that he has taken it there with the same
kind of of integrity that I tried to do
and to to articulate
so I I think him for that it was he
helped me that evening to a closing of
my artistic life and it was he put the
button on it for me and I'm indebted to
him